une première dans les yvelines l'école
de parfumerie estime qu'à implantée à
versailles a lancé ce 31 octobre son
look une formation en ligne ouverte à
tous le site propose gratuitement
jusqu'au 3 décembre des vidéos des
explications et des questionnaires sur
le monde top secret de la parfumerie
l'objectif c'est vraiment de faire
découvrir la parfumerie au grand public
aux passionnés une parfumerie qui est
souvent jugée comme étant un peu
confidentiel un peu secrète et donc de
permettre de découvrir le procédé qui
consiste à créer un parfum
choisir des matières premières les
formules et les réunir ensemble c'est
vrai que le parfum peut avoir un côté un
peu scientifique et casser cette
barrière qui peut freiner certaines
personnes à comprendre effectivement un
peu mieux la
le process de fabrication création d'un
parfum à ce jour plus de 4800 personnes
se sont déjà inscrites pour suivre les
cours on retrouve dans ces participants
des centaines d'étudiants originaires de
toute la france c'est un outil
supplémentaire et je pense qu'il ya
aussi des petites capsules ou des
informations complémentaires qu'ils
n'auront pas forcément dans leurs dans
leur formation on a vu notamment toute
une partie vraiment très techniques sur
la compréhension de l'olfaction et
comment se passe le faction ces choses
qui sont renseignés mais peut-être de
manière un petit peu plus rapide au sein
de l'école et qui leur permettent
d'avoir quelque chose d'un peu plus
pointu par rapport à ça au regard du
succès de cette première édition une
deuxième version du mook de disciples
cas devrait être programmée l'année
prochaine en version française et en
anglais pour participer à cette
expérience vous pouvez vous inscrire
jusqu'au 14 novembre